hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to inch by inch in this game
you are a scientist who unfortunately
are shrinking in height every single
second can you find the antidote before
it's too late and you are too short a
new day at the lab let's get started
what I need now is ignatiev luckily
there's some of my desk let's pick it up
time for some science let's put this
ignaty 'm into the distiller ater okay
this machine needs two ingredients so
let's get some water and put it into the
distill a door - okay and this will make
explode iam I don't like the sound of
explode iam but okay alright I have
water it's somehow created a beaker out
of it - so that's awfully convenient for
me huh only need out in two dudes and
determine the distill later on wait for
a moment okay
voila explode iam which I something
tells me I shouldn't be this careless
with explode iam next step is to put
this new ingredient in the bioreactor
the bioreactor only takes a single
ingredient but also requires a code to
be programmed okay not to go down put in
one of the drawers just can't remember
which one no right no easy enough for me
entering the wrong code could yield
unexpected results I'd lewd this expose
iam and would have to start over
okay well that beasts be goddamn
terrible huh oh there it is this is the
formula I need to the correct code for
the bioreactor 1 7 2 8 3 ok 7 2 8 3
perfect it worked
now let's wait for a moment explode iam
+ 7 2 8 3 equals then no Liam and what
do I do with this microwave
that doesn't seem like a good idea to do
with anything in a lab what would a lab
even have a microwave all I need now is
to do this a little bit alright the
microwave is a lot easier to use in the
other machines but also takes longest to
finish alright ok what am I gonna start
shrinking huh jeez this takes ages also
this game you start out at the wonderful
height of 5 foot 10 which is exactly
what
my height is and we're gonna go down
from there so I I'm not short yet I'm
gonna be short finally just what I need
right now
odd coffee a nice cuppa something tells
me this ain't coffee one it looks -
poopy to be coffee and number three I
don't know how explode iam turned into
coffee now the real work can begin
oh that was it I kind of feel funny uh
kind of feel that shortness coming long
maybe I should stop using our lab
equipment to make coffee left a good old
five foot ten what's this I'm shrinking
okay okay no panic no panic no panic
here all I need are three components
from the antidote the formula
ingredients have to be around here
somewhere all right I got it now um
should I put that in the decelerator
what about what about Z no Liam okay
activate while I'm waiting I should keep
looking for the other ingredients okay I
got it sodium I don't know what to do it
ago diem if I get too small I may need
stairs and bridges to get this equipment
okay all right what do I do is odium I
should build some from random objects
well I still can wear a dude alright
I'll put this here I suppose a five foot
six a whopping five foot six I must have
gotten the formula wrong I have to
revert this and try again
however what I must put this useless
ingredient in the chemical reverter
right below the bookshelf oh I'm getting
shorter it's my worst nightmare what am
I gonna where's the god oh god damn
bookshelf Oh a diary oh no no no okay
alright well that's gonna go Whippany
wobbly woobeewoo
we're gonna put this here we're gonna
create a little bridge there - there is
an only m plus links IAM equals explode
'i'm well okay alright wait no that's
but i did water extent only impress
links iam alright okay can I have my was
a no Liam alright we're gonna do this
why do I need to make you slow diem
again low sodium well where's the got in
cold
yeah there's gonna be a problem mmm um
here and there I guess
oh [ __ ] I'm in some kind of trouble here
I'm four foot four said I was Oh nanny
and plus some microwave equals key three
key three what is key three mean how
many keys are there oh boy okay
exploding plus 2 7 4 3 equals key one
key one kick key 1 ok wait hang on oh
god I'm getting so short okay what was
it Pepa d hoppity hippity hippity ha
okay two seven four three okay two seven
four three
all right that's gonna make key one and
then uh Natyam plus microwave I have
Ignacio don't have a cannot iam driving
I have ignore him
oh the microwave too high huh there we
go
okay big Natyam underway what else is
there there's gotta be more right oh boy
damn it I'm getting too short to reach
the table no I died of a perfectly
capable hand me height there's got to be
like a clipboard up here or something
something I should've looked at when I
was taller Oh No Oh hurry up oh oh titty
sprinkles I am I am all kind I'm two
foot 11 that short wait no I seem to be
a perfectly reasonable height not two
foot 11 I don't have enough for the
other keys I okay key one the first key
ingredient it goes in the antidote
processor next to the computer it's so
high there we go okay I got one
I need more can I can step on a boot all
right that's my is my table oh yeah I
have no idea what the other keys would
be I'm just kind of stuck in a perpetual
loop of two foot Fordyce what do I do
with explode iam XO diem what do I do a
sec sodium what what do I do it so do
please do something about it sodium I uh
no come on please please
alright so tiny maybe I can put you in
the chemical reverter no no oh God or
how about
Distiller ater + water is the only thing
I didn't think of pick it up get up I
can't pick that up some of these objects
are getting way too big and heavy for me
well tough it up 1 foot 8 me I can only
carry increasingly small items well this
is make any sense I gotta go I should
think ahead and get the larger ones
first
okay sure Oh key my second key
ingredient quickly add it to the
ingredient
okay alright I've got two three I think
oh I'm so boned only one more oh there's
only one oh there's no way that's gonna
be the key ingredient i watch before i
drinking help help I'm not short I'm
perfectly average height oh please give
a gift I don't know what you're gonna
make but please make something good for
me that tylium Tyler please I can't
reach it is I don't think this is it Oh
everything's so big oh I'm a big boy
okay oh oh tylium plus two eight six six
oh please I I'm not tall enough to be
able to get up there Oh put it in there
okay
tweet six six I gotta get something to
get up a little higher I need that boot
oh I'm one foot one oh I'm what I've
always said I so happy oh my god okay
maybe I'll do it like this yeah okay
okay please please oh no okay I'll just
jump on the bow [ __ ] okay I'll just jump
on the boot uh give me oh no oh no come
on come on come on please
that's good enough yes okay what was it
two eight six six two two eight six six
answer okay why are you doing that I'm
gonna go try to figure out a better
bridge for a bat over there I can't pick
it up I got a book books are my only
friend
knowledge is power oh my god oh my god
I'm so tiny
ah oh no oh please please please don't
get the boot on the thing boot on you
and then that'll be enough to get yes
okay for now it's not for long I I can't
jump on that can I
oh yes just barely okay you're gonna
give me this come on come on nine inches
tall I mean if you round up to ten I'm
ten inches tall that's good that is good
how can I um maybe I could use like
these two because just gonna throw them
down just cuz it's all I got
okay yes give give give this is the last
one
the antidote that's it that's the last
ingredient okay give oh my god okay here
I go if I don't known about that good
thing I looked out on the water okay no
oh no no if I open that drawer maybe
maybe they'll get me up come on no let's
go let's go come on
open the drawer over there I'm in the
booth I'm stuck in the booth I'm in the
boot in the boot this is a pathetic and
I have to wait all the way for seven
inches oh this is [ __ ] oh this is
[ __ ] pissed off I just have to be
mad and small inside this no stupid
this is stupid if I had a bill better if
I could be I dropped the book I dropped
the notepad and like the thing I could
have made like a ramp uh this is ed this
is that I could have beat this I could
have beat this I could have it there's
no problem if I hadn't been an ass hole
this is getting ridiculous
yeah I know I mean a frickin boot I
don't have a way to climb these tables
there's no way I can finish the antidote
at this size I know I I'm true
oh wait whoa I gotta have the boot but
no it's do it jump on the drawer ah well
Teddy sprinkle me Oh youyou really oh
you give me a sliver of hope and then
you throw it down my throat ah come on
I'm not small I had perfectly normal
average height
oh it's gonna
in the game on me I'm a strong boy but
this is really heavy ah tense why did
why couldn't I get out of the booth
before dam duk God oh oh oh oh I I think
I'm too small to use any of the
equipment yeah all right let's try this
again
your cone iam plus microwave equals
ingredient three okay what do we got for
chronium microwave
pop pop that bad boy in let's do this
okay we got strawberry jam with the
strawberry jam
why don't we need strawberry jam all
right whatever I got all the ingredients
there there okay let's look for this
goddamn clipboard there's probably gonna
be two clipboards again there's one of
them okay this is a strawberry jam plus
lyceum was i steamed
strawberry jam plus links 'i'm links IAM
equals iced tea for some reason that's
important oh that's already there okay
let's make the boot I think I should be
able to get from the boot of that but
just in case let me put like a book
underneath it look then boot and that'll
be enough to get me up there probably
look at this here just in case no god
damn it okay I've got this is this a key
ingredient I don't know hubby dooby
dooby doo
iced tea plus six seven one nine okay
iced tea
six seven one nine I am dating shorty
short why am I so shorty short I need to
find one more clipboard there's got to
be another clipboard to here somewhere
whoa 90 M plus 703 six okay I've got
that that's that's important I'm gonna
put that on the ground
just in case I see that later got it one
of them okay first key ingredient put
that in the bad boy that's going in that
fat boy and and they say it's gone where
did I throw that okay aghh not him it
was dark iam I don't know what the [ __ ]
dark iam does I don't have anything dark
him dark dark dark iam plus water equals
key to okay
as soon as I make if not him I'm gonna
make dark iam okay this is ready put
this in here I'll make some dark iam put
this in there okay take me give no hear
you and then what's goat 703 six okay
703 I'm really losing a height quickly
there then food on you now
boot on you stay one three-foot far I
need water
uh-uh water give me water how long does
it possibly take to get water give me
give me give me give me you give me give
me
you oh it's so heavy blow okay water
mine come on okay dork iam got it okay
dark iam plus water equals key to I
think yes
dark iam go come on baby come on baby
I'm about to head to feet I hope it
doesn't pause me at the high I am if it
does then that's kind of [ __ ]
because I am a perfectly average 5 foot
10 and I'm happy with that if there's an
antidote that can make me taller that
would be really great hurry the hell up
anybody doubt would be really cool okay
okay cool get goob okay that's it that's
the last key ingredient I need here I go
okay got it in there I need to go up I
did it I've stopped straight what how do
I get big again
[Music]
oh okay all right
this has been inch by inch it's a really
clever idea I feel like they could
expand this in a big way if they put
more effort into the the the levels in
like the intricacies of it it's it's
kind of an interesting concept to fight
against the clock by shrinking and the
challenges that it presents are really
interesting so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below if you
have any other suggestions for games
that you would like me to play no I'm
not sure it if you think I'm not sure
right I'm not sure down in the comments
below
you think I'm a perfectly average height
then yeah I'd say that as well also
we're going to Australia and Amsterdam
check out toor dhal markiplier comc for
government to you real soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know anything down the comments below
and as always see you in the next video
[Music]